Let's take our usual approach--
start making an inventory of concepts and figure how to represent them.
We want to represent a person, a collection of people,
and probably it looks like we want to have two collections of people.
One, the collection of people on the here side,
and one, the collection of people on the there side.
We also need to represent the light or the torch.
From there it seems like that's about it,
and the other concepts we need are the concepts we already had
of states and paths.
Now, how about the representation choices.
For person, well, I hate to reduce people to numbers,
but in this case that seems like the perfect thing to do.
This person, regardless of all his wonderful individual qualities,
we can just represent by the number 5.
How about a collection of people?
We could represent a collection as a tuple--1, 2, 5, 10--
as a list, as a set. There's also this data type in Python called a frozen set.
What I want you to tell me is of these four, which do you think would be okay for representations
just in terms of being able to to manipulate them and calculate the successors.
Which of these are hashable?
Hashable is important, because if we're going to use the same type of technique we used before
for our search we had our explored set, which was a set of states,
and members of a set have to be hashable.
That's a property that we might want to worry about.
Now, I should say one more thing
in that the description of the problem it was explicitly stated that each of the people
has different speeds.
That bothered me a little bit, because I could certainly imagine two people having the same speed.
But let's just solve what we were asked to solve where every person has a distinct speed.